miss Shay Mitchell congratulations
entrepreneur of the year what does that
mean I mean you kind of really exploded
your business your brand over the past
year it is so incredible and such an
honor to get this award tonight revolve
is an amazing partner to us and it's
been a supporter from day one so it's
really really awesome to be recognized
for this and yeah I'm excited to be out
yes yes I'm also very excited for
Dollface it's out this weekend out it is
out now yes all 10 episodes so distri
music and it's what I love about you is
that you always pick roles that are
strong females and also that focus on
strong female friendships how
intentional is that for you you know
what to be honest it's always comes down
to the script first and foremost and
this was just something I was super
excited to play Stella is the completely
different characters and anything that
I've ever done before and just the girls
are so wonderful so it was such an
amazing experience and yeah this is now
my third show in a row with an
all-female cast yeah I think she does
intentionally like only doing those kind
of shows yeah I love that I also got to
say big congratulations thank you mom
yeah it's wild it's wild even just
hearing that I'm still like oh ya know
it is the best thing ever she is so
impeccable and growing every single day
so I'm sleeping you know no no I'm not
sleeping in every new parent out there
is like no you are not but it is all
worth it and I wouldn't trade it what
have you learned most about yourself in
these past few weeks it's in a month now
yeah it's been a little over a month I
would say just how little sleep you
actually need to function so that is
what I've learned no one just to like
stop everything and just really take it
all in because they do grow so fast so
that's what I'm trying to do I know you
have your baseline and now you're doing
bass baby right what can you kind of
tease about that I will say that we are
gonna have the best diaper bag ever next
year I can proudly say that I've just
been testing them this
you're getting ready for it so we're
gonna be launching bass baby for the
first quarter of next year and I'm so
excited it's you know the direction that
I'm moving in and I can't wait to now
have products to suit this different
category yeah how else do you see the
Shay brand really expanding
I mean I'm dropping my music video
tomorrow my elbow is that is that the
thing that's happening just yet but
Never Say Never
hey watch out cardio I'm just kidding I
think what about a rise and shine viral
moment maybe maybe you never know no
it's just whatever I'm passionate about
you know and I'm so fortunate to be able
to have two babies right now based in
Atlas so I'm just loving life and we'll
see what happens I love her name do you
know the first place are gonna take her
to travel yeah Vancouver to visit
grandma so how bad is gonna be the first
place she is gonna go and see Canada
yeah Thanksgiving are well that's
American Thanksgiving we did our
Canadian Thanksgiving in October but
okay you're gonna celebrate American
Thanksgiving in Canada so that's really
fun though yeah what else are you doing
I mean it's your first holiday season as
a mom like does it feel different it
feels different I'm now shopping for her
more than for me really it's not about
my wardrobe anymore it's about her and
all the Christmas dresses I'm just super
excited to be able to celebrate this
holiday season our first one with her so
yeah how does it seem at as a dad it's
awesome but I always knew he was gonna
be an incredible dad so it's really cool
and he's like such a pro yeah are we
gonna see more pictures of her on your
Instagram or are you gonna be kind of
wary about that I would oppose whenever
I kind of feel like it you know um yeah
I think it's gonna be whenever kind of
feel like it that's how I've got it done
everything you feel like you don't care
as much now that your mom you let things
roll off your back you're more like a
mama bear has that changed I mean I feel
like I've always been kind of you know
easy back in the day but no now there
will be a lot more of the Bob at bear
come you know don't mess with her
otherwise otherwise have you thought
about a next role that you want that
you're interested in there are a couple
things that are in the works right now
so I'm super excited but again just
choosing product projects that I'm
and about and I've been so fortunate to
work with such incredible people so
playback continues as well and I
manifest something for you please do I
feel like I want to see you as a
superhero I would love that
yeah I would love that let's put that
out there right now anyone you'd love to
play honestly just badass strong female
characters is always what I go after and
yeah I'd love to do that yeah and before
I let you go have any of the PLL
co-stars met atlas yes I feel like we
bonded over PLL so I have to of course
Troian Bellisario yes she has been the
person I've gone to for the most advice
obviously having a daughter of her own
and yeah but no the other girls will
definitely be meeting her soon yes it's
fun that you and try and kind of got to
raise your kids at the same it's the
best I'm the luckiest person in the
world she is not only such an incredible
person but the best mom ever and so to
have her and give me advice is like more
than I could ever have
[Music]